do you guys would you like a Rayman game
or something sure Globox we avoided
Barbara again look I know you're
heartbroken
Ludi got it yeah okay I couldn't play
another card I just got excited when I
saw it was the same mark I feel like you
and I are just on the same wavelength
here man
okay thank you I doubt that with
improvement I mean it's kind of good
pretty good I'm just saying I doubt it
you know I mean it's pretty good I guess
no I don't believe you
I mean I'm looking right at it it's
pretty good there's no blue here I feel
like I've been bamboozled that's
pronounced bamboozled all right mark you
know your handbag okay no that's pretty
cold
what do you mean that's nice I loaned it
to me not giving it back with interest
you're gonna take it you gonna call him
out you know [ __ ] it I I'm I'm gonna
dude he would [ __ ] it why he'd be like
all right you know I think I'm tired I
think my slap-happy nature is starting
to Rhoda Kate erupt erupt mark yes sorry
we I think we need to work together okay
well what color do you want my dude
anything but blue sounds good to me
cool I almost did it blue just because
you said it like that but then I
realized I don't always have to be that
guy you know I could just don't you
don't have to be that guy really Bob you
win I do
Wow that it's just what drew I didn't
choose that then I just farmed that to
be nice we'll never sends it back my way
yeah you saw the packing lesson learned
I saw path along the path I hope we get
Barbara or doesn't not is it always
Globox oh oh yeah I think the room stays
the same
hey this is so nice and in blue oh look
at that so nice and blue oh it's so
beautiful blue let's make it red that
one's still blue
dude I'm sorry Globox dude
well that didn't work mark I'm sorry
here here for don't call it out what
maybe maybe enjoy that [ __ ] oh yeah get
them get them do your stuff no I'm gonna
break my 69 up my old friend Oh God
well that was old okay hey why is always
the D can it be a different nut blutter
I don't know why thank you
okay look look don't know the way my
mind works let me work okay that wasn't
that was way was that not what you know
it's gonna go differently oh all right
it's okay tell me next time like
specific together hey my expectations
and that's it's not fair of me to hold
you to that
all right Wow what it saw mark you all
my hand oh that's a that's a Dickey move
I drew both of those oh dear well there
we go buddy all right thanks Oh with
great power comes great ass what I can't
oh I'm not right not on Tuesdays hi oh
it actually is Tuesday I was almost just
like it is Tuesday though yeah sure is
do it do it do it do it I will
you won't Wow mark I'm giving you a
chance but you gotta win now what's
gonna happen Rock is ticking yeah okay
the clock
oh yeah Clark unless good clock club
closed Globox
that is rude number one thank you
deserve this buddy I'm gonna help you
out
that's not anybody else what try to jump
in and ruin this for me no that's not
cool this is interesting I should have
picked the color that he didn't have if
I knew it what that would be a great ass
Oh Globox yeah wait great power comes a
great powerful man combination of what
we just said and what happened to me
could you ever just be happy for my
great commentary Bob not all the time
man I'm just right now this moment fill
me with your comic about the real [ __ ]
you know with it you know he's gonna
plunge that I fight for your plumbing
issues with I have to sit here in
between the two of you an experience you
can plunger with us mark that's not how
discord works ask our oh my nips just
perked up as I said ask cards well that
added to it I was like an extra quarter
of an inch ooh that is a great color
blue is like pretty good oh wait no blue
sucks
now blue bad I'll take that hell yeah
hell yeah man I don't know what's
displayed green skin you got one you
won't you got you don't have one no you
lie you won't do it you will no bomb my
beautiful plan um
I see this is a good plan out there goes
Bob check out this plan oh [ __ ] it's
pretty good plan right okay this is
weird
wrong a split hey Bob what color you
need for that plan
green green yeah yeah there you go they
didn't get rid of the green just had the
four you know yeah the four yeah magic
that's the mark has to do is just not
hurt him okay that's not what you want
to listen because you because you have
made mistakes no I have a lot of cars be
nice you pissed it away I'm not trying
to win on some cheap handed to me Victor
I want to win because I earned it you
did yeah no it's lost it no way what no
I'm earning it either I am earning how I
earn it Bob goes to camp you earned this
see see how I earn things well yes okay
well I just want to say I appreciate
your friendship thank you buddy there
you go there you go
wouldn't that be something that you
would you would think it would be
enjoyable but like there's braces and
sharp teeth and knives maybe a barbecue
skewer happens in your head
I don't know what that one does okay I
did you really not have any yellows
right now oh that's odd choice but you
know I respect it cuz you got hood spot
yeah you gotta respect it well now I'm
going with the red I respect that too
just not as much not as much I don't
perhaps a nice blue would have been
prefer this way oh that's sweet baby
peen three I don't say the words baby
and peen next to each other you don't
yeah don't do that that's yeah I think
that was so I'm just gonna take it you
do yeah yeah I'm just gonna take it
that's them that's the man I have know
and love yeah me that's yeah that's the
one thanks man well I guess I'm playing
that one
[Music]
blue ha ha joke's on you and Joe Wow
greenie sick yeah that's what I say 9
that's a 9 do you laugh I'm not doing
this out of spite but I'm a man of who
plans and I have to fall through all my
plans I meant to do that
and I told you solution oh I have a
solution
white has a green card well I can I can
fix that why didn't you let me fix that
I could have mixed it whoa box fixed it
look no globe I could have fixed it I
could have fixed it low B want a
reliable and the fun friend you've been
look now now Bob you've earned this one
you've earned this you earned that
I did that I do to earn that I did not
do the other one out of spite that was
spite
that's spite Wow I feel like both of
those were on the spike I see I can tell
the difference between spite and right
and that was rightful spite thank you I
think are you on my side I'm on a side
wave get him everyone get him no you
can't get me no one can get me I'm
ungettable
told me to get you before you said not
to get you so I had to no I didn't say
no you couldn't get me you didn't get me
you may think you got me but I'm
ungettable Oh gotcha look at what
happened [ __ ]
what huh what's up gonna do something so
funny you didn't laugh but then I
couldn't there we go old friend
both spiteful spite all spite all over
you buddy
no that's spite no it's spite Wow he's
gonna like your cards really no I
enjoyed that very much you can't you
can't like it I did give a +2 sure don't
all right I wasn't but I thought the
comedic genius of the moment was just
too high right right
joke's on you I have one now take that
Wade chick that let's Bob yeah get Wade
eat suck on that
okay I won't have a turn that's fine
suck on my nards
okay I've raised my eyebrows of wrong
time there's it looked like I was trying
to say yes to the nards thank you for
informing me about your vow listen you
want them didn't even ask that time hey
do you plus two no they're all right I'm
gonna challenge you Wade there's no way
you have blue still all right you're
right I got nothing
Oh
see this is why no one gives you a win
[Music]
doesn't he that's me trying to beatbox
as a robot oh we could tell you was it
good
no all right I think I'm gonna pack it
in for the day I've got one more quick
game there's a quick one no no one more
quickie oh no we got one more quickie
listen my wife streams in five minutes I
gotta go five more minutes one quickie
no we gotta go quick Ino no force cuz I
like you I like you I like your stick oh
I like your stick a lot no your stick
your voice is telling me no no your bars
are telling me yes no I'll take that
I'll take that no I have not eaten today
period and I it sounds like a you
problem why would you do that to
yourself oh that's a nice quick no no
one hurts that one hurts a little bit
I'm a challenge a 15-car dude no way
there's a way what is will is away thank
you thank you guys I know you both want
me to go the pressure is mounting I
don't know what to do guess I'll play it
for cuz whatever the [ __ ] that is
deserves to get out of my hand oh man
thank you gotta get rid of this Smurf
Barbara okay well I'll go again right
man peace what color you need Bob Oh
Rhett oh I'm not Bob great minds think
okay work everybody it seemed work
pass at least it's out of the way early
you know it's done boom BAM we're over
with starting over a good game everybody
let's play here have a little fly guy
thing okay wait I'm fine oh I'm hungry
I'm hungry I why are we playing another
round then because I just my wife is
streaming soon I want to give her a
sweet raid
oh we had we had a rough evening
yesterday and I just I want to do
something nice for okay that's good you
know I'm just gonna draw I don't want to
hurt you so I'm gonna draw instead of
pie you're on board no sand you deserve
a nine-nine whoo I do I if I take I take
the plus for you hat what I will I will
take unless you want it back
no it's fine oh good yeah you know what
you have a turn
thank you [ __ ] you Globox I'm on board
with that yeah let's do that
yeah yeah oh yeah I'll take it Oh call
me Achilles cuz my ankle hurts yeah what
how he died right and ankle pain ankle
pain it's near the ankle yeah except
that is that good and they're part of an
Eminem song I guess that's why they call
it ankle pain that's windowpane
nevermind listen how much longer do we
have to do this I got a nice setup sorry
never mind
fine we'll speed round it round
everybody wins
I felt in my brain that I shouldn't but
then you know when what it's sitting
there in front of you and that
opportunity does not come around you
know what I mean
you know I mean you know you feel me
double twos boom game over we boom oh my
wrist just popped
I dislocated my hand really huh what you
okay I'll pop back I'll think on it pop
back oh god that hurt so [ __ ] bad
have you really judge as it's so hard by
my wrists look Oh
my whole left hand just like went limp
and popped out of place so stupid oh it
feels like something's pinched now
though not just stings my actions is
that the same hand that your pinkie
tingles on no it's the other all right
it's popping oh is it popping because
the wrist is not one bone it is like
seventeen bones no the hand bone
connects to the wrist bone mark did you
was I thinking
I wasn't expecting to jazz hands
dislocated thing no card in like five
minutes what's happening okay well sorry
that's all right yeah you should always
believe this is the speed round this is
the round of belief mark I will take
your sins you let my sins suffer your
sins they're mine now that's not what
you said I'll take your sis take them I
heard something else what do you think I
said I can't say what what would that be
I mean I legitimately thought I'll take
your sin I'll take no stop trying maybe
I don't want to know what you know
something you can't say that's bad bad
oh oh this would be good this is we good
Globox will suffer dearly and the rest
of us will be happy that's fine that's
that's just another seven oh that's
gonna be me or Bob Bob I'm so sorry
that's awkward
that wasn't expecting that move I didn't
realize that card would turn in
that it's not not my fault it's Globox
this fork in his dirty mind do you guys
know what he was never never mind it's
not a dirty mind when you hear her
mark what colour do you need uh you know
yellow green red anything blue you got
it
I do real bad I guess but that's ok who
cares my thing someone's like wait take
care of your hands and I at least
American never mind
nah keep going you know even Ethan
broken talk slower wait talk slower
masturbation is Molly on yes she went
live like I mean after we started this
and oh okay all right good good great
good
no Ethan's not break his hand
masturbating I'm saying he can't because
it's Ambrose oh never mind
yes Ethan broke his hand masturbating
spread that damn I don't want it well
read the rule here first cool shall we
shall we gentlemen yeah we could just
call it mark wins I think I'm into that
thank you yeah man thank you yeah well
okay everybody you know the deal this is
the most important rate of your life go
give my wife love like not the knot to
kind of make me jealous
[Music]